bonjour et bienvenue à bruxelles pour
europe hebdo l'émission européenne des
chaînes parlementaires bruxelles le
siège des institutions européennes mais
également bruxelles capitale de la
belgique
un état qui n'a plus de gouvernement
depuis près de trois cents jours alors
le royaume va-t-il exploser c'est la
question que nous poserons à notre
invité louis michel et puis nous parlons
également du portugal un pays en crise
politique également va-t-il devoir faire
appel à l'aide européenne
c'est la question posée par nora ahmadi
ces derniers temps l'europe avait la
tête ailleurs
sa pâle du ciom diplomatie empêtré dans
les révolutions arabes ses forces armées
dans la guerre en libye et cette
catastrophe nucléaire au japon
les 28 on avait presque oublié que leurs
propres problèmes et voilà c'est la
crise ce rappel à l'ordre aux souvenirs
au détour d'un conseil européen le
portugal c'est coates effort de pêche
ses couleurs chatoyantes et sa bête
83 % de son pib les agences de notation
dégradent et des gratte encore la note
du portugal et les taux d'intérêt
montent te faire
après la grèce et l'irlande l'union
propose de débloquer environ être 20
milliards d'euros du fonds de sauvegarde
mais josé socratès le premier ministre
socialiste refuse de faire appel aux
voisins pour éponger sa dette on s'en
sortira seul est maintenant à sa crise
économique s'ajoute une crise politique
après le refus du parlement de voter son
cinquième plan de rigueur de l'année
josé socratès a démissionné une
dissolution qui doit aboutir à de
nouvelles élections en mai un peu tard
quand les cas sinon on ose même le terme
de banqueroute
mais la banqueroute le peuple la respire
ciao las de subir plan de rigueur sur
plan de rigueur les portugais
s'essouffle manifeste grève et flirte
avec la pauvreté certains émigrent de
nouveau comme il ya 40 ans sous la
dictature de salazar et voit l'europe
comme vendus aux marchés financiers
alors que peut faire l'europe pour le
portugal
portugal on va y répondre dans un
instant avec nos deux invités nous avons
été rejoints par mario david bonjour je
vous êtes député européen portugais à
vos côtés se trouve jean paul gauzès
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen français on va évidemment
parler tous les trois du portugal je
voudrais juste vous poser une question
sur ce qui agite ici les couloirs du
parlement européen
certains députés ont été pris je dirais
la main dans le sac de cours sur une
affaire de corruption ils ont été pris
au piège par des journalistes du sunday
times j'aurais d'abord vous demandez à
tous les deux peut-être vous d'abord
monsieur david
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
affaire est ce que ça remet en cause la
crédibilité des institutions
on ne peut pas dire que ça mais la cause
la crédibilité de l'institution parce
que malheureusement quelques-uns de nos
collègues n'ont pas suivi les règles qui
doivent être à la base si vous n'êtes
pas pris mon propos non je ne me
surprend pas que parmi sept cent trente
et quelques il peut avoir des îles
permettront le mot je m'exprime dans la
langue qui n'est pas la mienne des bêtes
noires
n'est ce pas donc
nous on est pas on ne peut pas être tenu
responsable par le comportement si je
faisais quelque chose qui n'était pas
correcte jean paul ne pouvait pas être
responsables ni vous ni vice versa donc
dans un univers paraît effectivement
nous aurions souhaité que tout le monde
et une base de conduite et une ligne une
ligne afin d'aider procédure que ça ne
puisse pas être permis mais je voudrais
tout de même ajouté un tout petit mot
c'est que c'est absolument regrettable
que des collègues ont joué le jeu mais
aussi régler tabler au moins dans mon
pays la loi c'est la même pour les deux
côtés qu on ait essayé de leur faire
jouer ce jeu jean paul gauzès vous êtes
d'accord avec ça est ce que est ce que
diriez que ça pose un problème est ce
que par exemple où est-ce qu'on a déjà
tenté vous êtes sur des dossiers oui
j'en suis ce qu'on avance sensible
question financiers tant qu'il ya des
infractions en six ans de mandat
récemment sur les hedge funds sont qu'il
y avait beaucoup d'intérêt financier à
la fois des places financières
jamais on a proposé quoi que ce soit
bien sûr j'aurais pas accepter mais on
n'a jamais proposé
je relève dans cette affaire et je
partage tout à fait se dit mario mais je
relève dans cette affaire que on cible
les députés et derrière députés on
essaie de décrédibiliser l'euro je ne
trouve pas complètement paranoïaque de
constater que l'opération vient de
grande-bretagne et de patron du journal
c'est monsieur mur dog et je crois que
là on a ciblé les députés n'ont pas
l'opération on n'a pas ciblé un
lobbyiste vous redire il ya un lobby ce
qu'ils proposent de l'argent on envoie
des journalistes faire les photos ici
pour voir si des députés
ces dates vous répondez à une attaque
par une par une autre attaque ce qu'on
peut tout à fait comprendre d'un autre
côté si ce qui est dans les vidéos est
vrai c'est quand même assez grave non
mais je vous ai dit tout à l'heure je
partager ce qui a été dit je voulais pas
répéter c'est inadmissible scandaleux
choquant mais on ne peut pas parce qu'il
ya trois brebis galeuses éventuellement
parce que encore la présomption
d'innocence et la vidéo est elle bonne
chance et ria s'est vu les vidéos si on
se tient la vidéo c'est scandaleux
mais au-delà de ça on veut pas dire que
les 735 l'autre député ou sept cent
trente deux autres députés sont aussi
les pourris et qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut je prenais des mots qu'il
faut
il ya des règles claires mais je crois
que on est dans un domaine c'est comme
la compliance les entreprises
le problème de l'éthique aujourd'hui est
très important mais on n'enlèvera pas la
nécessité d'avoir une structure morale
et surtout d'avoir du bon sens parce
qu'en plus on nous donne l'impression
avec cette affaire que quand un député
dépose un amendement ça devient la loi
européenne c'est complètement faux il ya
tout un parcours qui fait qu'il ya 9
chances sur 10 ou 9 99 ans sur sol que
l'amendement ne sont pas repris tel quel
donc tout ça et est pas bien et c'est
pas bon pour notre parlement
c'est alors une autre un autre sujet
d'actualité européen très très important
c'est celui qui concerne le portugal
mario david dont vous êtes portugais est
ce que vous pensez que le gouvernement
portugais quel qu'il soit puisqu'on sait
qu' un gouvernement démissionnaire va
pouvoir éviter de demander l'aide à
l'europe et au fmi est ce que c'est
possible d'éviter cela tout d'abord ce
que je regrette c'est que depuis le
début de ces propos de ce procès le
premier ministre socialiste portugais a
essayé dé diaboliser le fonds monétaire
international et donc pour dire que
puisqu'il est attaché à un processus
européen avec 30%
donc il a refusé carrément dès le début
il a pris ça comme une éventuelle
défaite personnelle du fait que s'il
s'ils devaient s'ils devaient en as fait
ton grèce et en irlande alors général ça
se passait pas très bien pour le pour le
pour le pays pour le gouvernement fin ça
objectivement un impact quand même mais
à la fin avec qu'est ce qui est mieux
aujourd'hui les taux d'intérêt au
portugal sont à 8.5 la grèce près 4.8
donc les mesures qui sont prises
un hameau sûrement que soit ce
gouvernement soit le prochain devant les
prendre est-ce que malgré tout sur le
sur le fond est ce que ce que vous nous
dites aujourd'hui c'est que de toute
façon
objectivement le portugal ne peut pas
faire autrement que passer par une aide
européenne
moi je vois pas d'autres moyens jean
paul gauzès d'accord avec ça oui je
crois qu'il faut la solidarité l'aide
européenne mais en même temps il faut
donner au portugal les possibilités de
faire les réformes structurelles qui
n'ont pas été faites par les sociétés en
disant point que aujourd'hui on découvre
dans plusieurs pays des pays qui étaient
fragiles
des dettes importantes mais la situation
ne s'est pas créée en huit jours elle a
tout d'un coup explosé parce que c'est
venu sous les projecteurs parce qu'il ya
eu la notation la dégradation des notes
de ces pays des amis encore plus dense
et pas l'europe qui a refusé de voir la
réalité ce que vous parlez du proxy
l'hypocrisie mais ce qu'il n'y a pas une
hypocrisie de bruxelles je crois que le
rang parlement l'europe l'europe à sa
faute et c'est là et c'est à mon avis ce
qui justifie qu'on soit solidaires
aujourd'hui parce que ces pays
connaissent des difficultés au monde
l'entrée dans l'euro c'était pas évident
pour la plupart d'entre eux pour
certains d'entre eux sont prêts à la
grèce par exemple peut-être le portugal
et on a essayé l'europe a laissé faire a
été permissive
mais il faut bien voir aussi que lorsque
il s'est agi de d'appliquer strictement
le pacte stabilité il ya quelques années
quels sont les pays qui ont demandé à ce
qu'on la subissent ces deux grands pays
la france et l'allemagne
donc je crois qu'on a tous une part de
responsabilité dans cette situation ce
qu'il faut c'est regarder l'avenir et
donner aux pays qui sont dans le plus en
difficulté un espoir aux concitoyens et
c'est en les étranglant que on leur
donnera cet espoir il faut qu'il y ait à
la fois la rigueur et qu'il y aussi des
espoirs de croissance et pour procès là
que sert la population portugaise est ce
que je dirais le choix qui est qui a
fait ce n'est pas entre le en gros entre
la peste et le choléra c'est à dire
entre de toute façon une rigueur
disons portugais aux portugaises ou une
rigueur qui serait européenne en cette
rigueur je crois qu'elle doit être
partagé et
elle doit concerner tout le monde parce
que les divans ici tout le monde
c'est-à-dire toute l'europe toute
l'europe
je veux dire je veux dire enfin au moins
l'eurozone n'est ce pas et je crois à la
fin je devrais peut-être prendre la
phrase de kennedy il faut pas demander
ce que l'europe peut faire pour vous
c'est le portugais a tout d'abord qui
doivent régler nos problèmes
merci nous avons besoin d'aider à ce
moment ci et cette aide je crois que
cette soleil de solidarité on louera
pourvu que nous aussi que que les
marchés soit assuré que nous nous ferons
notre propre devoir il va se poser un
problème de timing puisque de toute
façon il faut au moins deux mois pour
organiser des élections à lisbonne est
ce que ça veut dire que d'ici là il va
rien se passer
mais françois ce que je peux pas
accepter c'est que mon parti ne pouvait
pas accepter c'était que dans les
projets du premier ministre socialiste
socratès il y avait le gel des pensions
des gens qui ont 187 euros par mo par
mois de pension les gel pendant trois
ans est ce que c'est ça des genres de
mesures qu'il faut prendre
vous disiez tout à l'heure vous êtes de
droite
enfin c'est lui qui s'y dit socialiste
il rappelle quand même pas en train
d'être prise un peu en otage parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya un effet domino
éventuellement qui peut y avoir derrière
il ya encore des inquiétudes sur
l'espagne
est ce qu'une crise politique interne au
portugal n'est pas en train de prendre
l'ensemble de l'europe en otage
on peut aussi si tu perds mais je dirais
je dirais ceci au début de la
conversation on a dit encore une fois
c'est c'était une campagne le monsieur
murdoch aider ces entreprises contre
leur offre sur le scandale là ça ne
m'étonnerait pas non plus que ce soit
aussi encore le monde anglo saxon
l'angleterre d'or parce que quand je
vois les agences de notation qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait avec lehman bros quelle
est la crédibilité qu'ils peuvent avoir
chaque jour on voit avant dégrade la
notation du portugal
les granges les grosses entreprises
portugaises électricité etc qui sont
très très bien qu'ils voient aussi être
dégradé leurs notations pourquoi ça
messieurs merci beaucoup
restez avec nous parce que ce qui suit
vous intéresse il ya un autre pays qui a
une crise politique alors qui dure
depuis plus longtemps encore qu'au
portugal c'est la belgique où nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui on sait que les
deux communautés n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord pour former un
gouvernement ça dure depuis près de
trois cents jours maintenant et ça se
voit également dans les médias que sont
les médias francophones et les médias
flamands qui sont totalement différents
regardez ce reportage qui a été fait
pour nous ici à bruxelles à la vrt la
télévision flamande et à la rtbf
un reportage signé marie brémond
oui mais tu as folk est limité les faits
ici
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
journal quatre deux journaux
d'information de rédaction de chaîne
télévisée publique
un seul pays bienvenue en belgique à
bruxelles plus exactement où cohabitent
côte à côte la rtbf francophones et
laverty flamande
c'est une frontière physique le bâtiment
qui se trouve par la haye le bâtiment de
la verte et la vlaamse radio télévision
et le bâtiment qui se trouve par là
c'est la radio télévision belge
francophone mais vous voyez qu'il ya
aucune difficulté je passe de l'un à
l'autre sans aucun garde-barrière c'est
bien à l'image de ce pays dire que on
est de plus en plus séparés mais on
passe toujours aussi facilement l'un
chez l'autre
de part et d'autre de cette frontière
linguistique il existe donc deux façons
de traiter de l'actualité de la crise
politique belge qui s'est installé
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
même si ce jour-là l'international fait
par tous les gros titres des villes de
bombardements quand on écoute les radios
tu le dis tout le monde a des positions
différentes à la zidane
mais quand on discute politique avec les
journalistes des deux télévisions
publiques
personne ne nie des approches bien
différente unique en belgique
quand on parle de la politique ou bien
flamand ou bien francophone donc dans ce
sens là je pense qu'on est forcément un
peu partisan
quand vous regardez les deux journaux
télévisé de la rtbf et de la vrt donc de
nous de nos confrères et collègues
collègues flamands c'est pas
nécessairement par exemple mêmes sujets
qui font qu'ils font la une quand
l'actualité strictement est strictement
belge oui j'en pleure encore le terme
le terme est belle
et oui car malgré une actualité
flamandes et wallonnes
les journalistes de la rtbf comme de la
vrt parle ton corps de belgique en
tentant de rester des observateurs
extérieurs au confluent politique et
culturelle qui ce que le film mais
journaliste politique belge reste une
équation périlleuse nous faisons très
attention à éviter de stigmatiser à
éviter de remonter les communautés les
unes contre les autres comme nous
évitons de remonter les communautés
étrangères les unes contre les autres ou
d'origine étrangère avec les communautés
d'origine belge
donc on n'est pas là pour attiser le feu
pour autant on est bien là pour décrire
l'instant l'igad il a lieu la première
chose qu'il faut faire c'est de
critiquer le point de vue de sa future
communauté mais c'est difficile parce
qu'il ya évidemment très vite un
consensus que nous avons raison et les
autres n'ont pas à l'image de ces
dizaines de magnétoscope entassés la
cohabitation des deux rédactions révèle
bien des surprises d'un point de vue
logistique le responsable rtbf des
bâtiments apparaît dépité voire même
désoeuvrés c'est un peu le reflet de la
belgique ici on essaie de se partager
les restants d'une belgique unitaire
c'est malheureux a montré avec moi faute
d'entretien des milliers de mètres
carrés sont laissés à l'abandon face aux
parties communes dégradé l'inertie et la
seule réponse on rencontre généralement
des difficultés sur sur le partage des
coûts entre la vrt la rtbf
un exemple on le trouve là bas il faut
faire des travaux de carrelage tout
simple sur quelques mètres carrés et
depuis cinq ans personne intervient
parce que on se rejettent mutuellement
la responsabilité de ces travaux on est
dans le même bâtiment comment et le
virus du séparatisme viendra-t-il à bout
de cette cohabitation au sud comme au
nord de la frontière linguistique du
paquebot télévisuelle les optimistes
sont rares l'avenir de la rtbf et de la
vrt se joue avant tout sur la scène
politique
voilà donc pour ce reportage signé marie
brémaud alors nous avons été rejoint sur
ce plateau par louis michel bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes député européen
vous êtes belge francophone vous avez
est également commissaire européen au
développement dans la commission barroso
1 c'est-à-dire la commission précédente
vous avez été ministre des affaires
étrangères de la belgique
chef d'un parti belge le m r quand on
voit ce reportage sur la scission entre
les médias francophones et les médias
néerlandophones est ce que vous diriez
qu'il reste des points communs entre les
deux communautés en belgique et est
énormément de points communs
parce que d'abord on a une histoire
commune qui qui est quand même déjà très
longue on a aussi un gouvernement qui
traitent des matières en commun et le
tout le débat évidemment c'est de savoir
si chacune de ces communautés chacune de
ces régions va finalement lui voir
attribuer des compétences plus
importante
je pense que c'est une choix fut une
appétence de la flandre pour plus
d'autonomie parce que c'est un nombre de
personnes en flandre et sans doute à
juste titre pense le ce serait mieux
d'avoir plus de compétences dans plus
son destin économique notamment en main
du côté francophone on n'est pas opposé
à ça le problème c'est que il faut
trouver une méthode qui ne provoque pas
de choc brutal institutionnel qui aurait
des répercussions et sur le plan social
et sur le plan économique pour la
wallonie principalement et bruxelles
mais trouver une méthode quand on voit
que ça fait quasiment 10 mois que les
hommes politiques belges n'arrivent pas
à trouver cette méthode quand on voit
que les citoyens belges
alors il reste patient quand même
globalement il ya quand même des petits
signes un peu d'impatience
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur dire ça va
durer encore longtemps que je pense que
ça va encore durer un certain temps ça
va durer le temps qu'il faudra à la fois
au parti dominant flamands qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement est un parti
nationaliste il faut bien se rendre
compte que ça c'est beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup plus grave ou de l'indépendance
de la flambée oui et donc nécessairement
avoir confiance quand on est un
interlocuteur d'un parti nationaliste
qui domine la flandre et qui d'une
certaine manière fait pression sur les
autres partis qui se sont tétanisés bien
entendu par le succès de ce parti c'est
évidemment difficile de gagner la
confiance et d'avoir en face des
francophones qu'ils puissent se dire
s'il ya un accord il sera de bonne foi
et cet accord n'est pas une phase
intermédiaire vers le séparatisme kurde
quand on fait juste j'ai regardé un peu
les derniers sondages
en flandre qui donne donc des
estimations on est passé pas un vote 1
mais la nva donc le parti
indépendantiste à 33%
le vlaams belang keita parti d'extrême
droite qui serait lieu aux alentours de
13% si on rajoute un autre parti
d'extrême droite qui à 3%
on arrive à peu près 40 9% dans ce
sondage de flamands qui donneraient leur
voix à un parti qui veut l'indépendance
est ce que ça veut dire que la flandre
veut partir non je suis intimement
convaincu que non j'ai énormément d'amis
en flandre étant parfaitement bilingue
et faisant beaucoup de conférences en
flandre est bien non ce n'est pas ça le
ce que je crois c'est que beaucoup de
flamands ne comprennent pas que l'on en
soit arrivé un blocage pareil simplement
pour la scission de l'arrondissement
électoral qu'il faut de toute façon à un
moment donné scinder le problème c'est
de savoir comment on le scindant on
continue à protéger par des facilités
public est assis sur sa selle c'est très
compliqué pour les français mais c'est
devenu si c'est assez facile de vous
dire il ya des francophones qui sont
majoritaires dans des communes flamandes
qui bénéficient de façon à bruxelles oui
qui bénéficient en fait de faciliter au
quotidien dans le rapport avec leur
commune par exemple ils peuvent remplir
des papiers en france et ses remords et
sa des facilités et ce n'est pas grave
ce n'est pas un concept mais ils sont
forts mais ils sont en flandre et ir
depuis toujours une lutte
en flandre pour dire c'est comme ne sont
chez nous donc la langue c'est le seul
flamand et donc son c'est un débat qui
est réglée l'air d'un peu émotionnel
dans le fond louis michel est ce que
vous pensez que vous parliez tout à
l'heure d'un agenda vous allez dis vous
aviez dit que ça allait durer assez
longtemps au mois de juin cela fera un
an que les élections ont eu lieu lorsque
vous pensez que d'ici mois de juin une
solution a été trouvée en belgique je ne
suis pas si sûr mais elle pouvait
dépasser l'année je pense qu'on pourrait
dépasser l'année je ne le souhaite pas
bien entendu mais en fait il faut tout
simplement que du côté flamand on
comprenne que pour aller beaucoup plus
loin dans une réforme de l'état que nous
pouvons accepter
il faut que nous ayons des garanties que
cette réforme ne va pas appauvrir nos
concitoyens wallon et francophone et du
côté francophone il faut aussi ça c'est
vrai que nous acceptions que l'autonomie
qu'on va nous accorder en plus eh bien
nous la finance y ont par une
contribution de nos citoyens à nous
c'est à dire par une responsabilité
fiscale plus grande qu'aujourd'hui faire
également un effort avant lui michel
vous êtes député européen les
institutions européennes sont basés ici
à bruxelles est la situation de la
belgique est évidemment une situation
qui inquiète même si on n'en parle pas
d'ailleurs au niveau des institutions
européennes regardez ces quelques
paroles de députés européens comme vous
que nous avons recueillis ici au
parlement
c'est pas impossible je pense que
stupide je pense que tout doit être fait
pour l'empêcher
ça n'a aucun sens c'est un espèce de
mirage un rêve que certains
nationalistes foot porte et ils cachent
derrière ça l'idée le concept d' europe
des régions à jour les régions belges
bien sûr que les régions de l'importance
mais est ce qu'on imagine un jour qu'on
va avoir une europe avec 272 e 280
région aux conseils de voyage à 27 comme
ça difficile un conseil donc je pense
qu'ils essayent de surtout de gagner du
terrain sur leurs revendications
nationalistes
je pense pas que la séparation est à
l'ordre du jour je ne vois pas un risque
que la belgique se divise en deux ou
même trois je pourrais imaginer une
situation où il y aura un bruxelles
décès comme washington dc comme capitale
de l'europe
mais je pense que les intérêts de la
belgique
ce sont de rester ensemble ce que nous
pouvons faire c'est que par le biais de
cette réforme institutionnelle aucune
des régions de s'appauvrissent l'adn qui
est une sorte de démocratie économique
meilleure que celle qui existe
aujourd'hui qui s'installe et ça s'est
compliqué est aussi espéré
finalement le bon sens prévaudra et
l'attachement à la belgique très voudra
le nombre d'états de l'europe évolué bon
c'est qu'elle a commencé à 6 e demain
avec l'entrée de la croatie sera 28
qu'il y ait des états qui viennent de
l'extérieur pour rejoindre l'europe
c'est une chose que l'on admet qu il
peut y avoir des états qui viennent de
l'intérieur parce que à l'intérieur des
états membres tels qu'ils étaient en
1955 et eu des évolutions et que ces
évolutions doivent être prises en compte
et elle doit être prise en compte sur
une seule base que la volonté
démocratique des peuples concernés
on a beau dire que
soit disant l'europe fm je pense que
c'est bien parce qu'il y a l'union
européenne qui tient qui assure je
dirais un cadre stable qu'on assiste
dans plusieurs états membres alors pas
forcément comme en belgique mais a des
tas de tension régionale et à la remise
en cause du niveau du niveau national
alors voilà pour ces micro trottoir
comme on dit deux députés européens les
français se posent la question c'est la
question qui évoquait ici
est-ce que la belgique va se séparer non
jamais la belgique tout restant toujours
le belge eric woerth va rester à ce que
ben c'est qu'on veuille faire ce qu'il
sait pas on voit pas normalement il doit
faire qui va faire que ça va marcher
c'est que il y aura une nouvelle
architecture institutionnelle avec
beaucoup plus de compétences aux régions
avec le maintien dans l'état fédéral
les grandes fonctions régaliennes la
sécurité probablement là juste la
sécurité sociale fédérale je suis
intimement convaincu parce que c'est ça
aussi la crainte francophone il est
évident qu'il ya un différentiel en
termes de produit intérieur brut par
exemple entre la wallonie et la flandre
l'avion dans le riche oui et donc il
faut du tout aimé la violoniste occupés
à reprendre des couleurs
et donc il faudra nécessairement un peu
tant d'options introduit des phase
transitoire pour aller vers plus
d'autonomie
on doit pouvoir y vais pour les mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que les francophones
pour devoir accepter
je suis favorable à ça moi une une
profonde réforme institutionnelle avec
beaucoup plus d'autonomie et ce qu'il y
avait une vraie envie de rester ensemble
parce que du côté flamand
bon on a entendu ce que vous nous disiez
mais malgré tout les chiffres sont là et
du côté francophone on a un peu le
sentiment que maintenant beaucoup de
francophones dit pape après tout si les
flammes rigole c'est à dire qu'ils y
arrivent non mais ça s'annonce et du
fatalisme fondée sur l'émotion parce
qu'évidemment ça devient motionnaire
mais les politiques c'est par le crawl
d'exciter l'émotion des gens les
politiques doivent aussi faire de la
pédagogie et l'intérêt et des flamands
et des francophones
c'est de rester ensemble on pèse
beaucoup plus par exemple sur la scène
internationale
que séparément ses dents sur la scène
internationale et jusqu'aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que c'est un un pays un
groupe i moyens bon il est évident que
demain si on devait se séparer
que ce soit la flandre la wallonie ou la
belgique francophone parce que c'est
encore un scénario possible
bon on posera beaucoup moins et je ne
vois pas très bien quel est l'intérêt de
faire simple si la belgique venait à se
séparer là encore une fois on est à
bruxelles on est au coeur de l'europe
quel exemple ça serait pour l'heure pour
l'europe à ce serait dramatique parce
que ce serait un précédent qui se serait
pour la première fois dans l'europe
qu'un pays
ça donnerait si vous voulez au jeu
pervers des nationalismes parce que dans
le fond le vrai différentiel vrai
dichotomie est là du côté francophone
nous allons voler pas nationaliste là
mais aucun politique nationaliste et
s'il y en a ils sont en exil qui veulent
aller vers la france mais c'est pas des
étangs des indépendantistes ont ni ne
veulent pas née taiwan ont ils veulent
se rattacher à la france par contre du
côté flamand et bien vous avez un
courant que l'on peut estimer devrait
nationaliste et devrait
l'indépendantisme vous avez un courant
qu'on peut estimer entretien et 20%
tout le reste c'est en fait de la
spéculation politique c'est c'est courir
après monsieur de wever sait tout ça
mais le nationalisme ou
l'indépendantisme ne vit pas
majoritairement dans la population pas
d'inquiétude en quelques mots vous être
inquiet il faut juste attendre et
accepter ça c'est vrai accepter une
réforme assez radical michel merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté cette
invitation on va poursuivre avec notre
chronique avec europe direct avec une
question qui nous est posée par marie de
grenoble mari nous dit je pars étudié en
irlande dans le cadre du programme
erasmus suis-je couvertes par
l'assurance maladie française
voici la réponse d'europe direct
bonjour marie oui la carte européenne
d'assurance maladie peut couvrir le soin
de vous serez besoin dans votre ce jour
toutefois il peut y avoir de limite
d'âge
donc avant de partir et de recevoir
votre assurance maladie pour vérifier si
vous remplissez toutes les conditions
voilà si vous aussi vous avez une
question très concrète à poser sur
l'europe et bien vous pouvez composer le
0 0 800 6 7 8 9 10 11
le coup de filet gratuit d'un téléphone
fixe partout en europe voilà c'est la
fin d'europe hebdo merci de votre
fidélité et bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires
non